Obviously animals can talk if they couldn't,
would we named social chat services after them?
When we say animals, we're not usually talking about humans.
We have this intuition that humans are very different from the rest of nature,
but if we are so special, the searches on for what makes us special,
the first thing to reach for is often human language. We can talk to each other.
Sure, but the rest of the animal kingdom, blank stares.
What about animals that can communicate Ansley pheromone trails that other ants
can sniff out with their antenna.
These dads to tell the high where to find flowers.
Birds learn to sing and their songs can communicate various details to other
birds, but as any of this really language to sort this matter out,
linguists ethologists and biologists came up with lists of things that make a
language a language.
It's actually not an easy thing to do before you look at these,
go try making your own. Take one of the items that ends up on these lists.
Displacement,
animals adopt postures or vocalizations to signal an opportunity or warn of
immediate danger,
but displacement signaling about something removed from our surroundings,
something far away,
something in the past or the future that seems legitimately rare but not for
humans. You'll catch this languaging. Displacement all over the place.
We're not the only ones though.
Enter the honeybee who performs a waggling rotating dance that contains
information about the direction and distance of a point of interest.
This waggle dance definitely has this placement,
but it doesn't have double articulation.
Also known as duality of patterning.
Double articulation gives humans a layer of meaningless sounds that we can put
together and switch around like building blocks to create a meaningful layer of
words and sentences. Linguists argue that these two levels,
meaningless pieces we use to build up meaning makes us more flexible talkers
than we'd be if our smallest communication units were already packed with
meaning. Like if we communicated by pointing to pictures of real world objects.
Wait, you hear that there's a low rumble building up in the audience?
Hold on. What about apes?
Didn't coco the gorilla cry when she was told that Robin Williams died? I mean,
that sounds like displacement and it sounds like sadness and doesn't she use
sign language to build meaning out of simple gestures? I mean,
that's double articulation right there. Okay,
let's come back to that.
But what do you think languages and I do other animals have it set a straight in
the comments and subscribe for language.